- Oh, you said your grandma is
looking forward to watch you.
- Yes.
- On YouTube, right?
- Yes, yes.
- Do you wanna say hi to your grandma?
- Hi, grandmom.
- Shout out.
(screen beeps)
Hi, I'm Rie.
Today, I've been challenged
to take a popular food and...
Make it fancy.
- Make it fancy.
- You did it.
Today, I have a special guest.
She's a big "Make It Fancy" fan.
Ceara!
- Hi, Rie. Thank you for having me.
- Yeah, thank you for coming.
She flew from Atlanta.
It's across the country.
It's a big deal.
Ceara, what am I making fancy today?
- Today, you are making
fancy a Starbucks lemon loaf.
- I love lemon pound cake.
- It's like a good little treat,
and I love lemon-flavored things.
- I also feel like this is already fancy.
- That's what I thought, too.
It's a little fancy. It's a little boujee.
- Yeah. It smells so good.
- It's so good.
- I like this.
It's not too sweet.
- Mm-hmm.
- The texture is very soft and moist.
- I think it would be really
unexpected and really cool
if you made something savory out of this.
- Challenge accepted.
But you have to help me.
- That sounds good.
- Co-pilot.
- Challenge accepted.
- All right. (laughs)
Make it fancy.
- Make it fancy.
(upbeat music)
- All right here what I bought.
Ricotta cheese.
- Parsley.
- Pea shoots.
- Basil.
- Dragon fruit powder.
- Celery.
- Heavy cream.
- Butter.
- Edible flowers.
- Parmesan cheese.
- Yellow onion.
- Chives.
- Thyme.
- Carrots.
- Eggs.
- Lobster tails.
- And black truffle.
From the pantry, I got semolina flower
- Lemons.
- Double-0 flour.
- Bay leaves.
- Garlic.
- And shallots.
- All right, let's get started.
Make it fancy.
- Make it fancy.
- So the first step,
we're gonna do a surgery.
We are going to remove
icing from the pound cake.
It's a very serious surgery.
It's very serious.
- Did you ever play Operation?
- No. What is that?
- It's a game, and
there's this little guy,
and he has these random
objects in his body,
and you have to remove them with tweezers,
but if the tweezers touch
anything but the little object,
he gets electrocuted.
- It sounds horrifying.
- It's a kid's game, so it's fine.
- It's a kid's game?
Our surgery almost done.
You're gonna just put this in a bowl.
Just break it.
We're gonna use it for later.
And I'm going to dehydrate
this pound cake until crispy.
Do you have any guesses
so far what I'm making?
- No, but I feel like we're
having a little breadcrumb,
crouton moment with this.
- Hmm. We will see.
- We will.
- Yeah, we are cooking
together, but Ceara has no idea.
- Nope.
- I'm going to put this in a dehydrator,
and we are moving on to next step.
All right, so it has been dehydrated.
Can you tell?
- No, it looks the same.
- Three, two, one, crush.
- Or not.
It's crunchy, though.
- Crunchy. Do you wanna try it?
Mm!
- That is really good.
- It's tasty.
- Reminds me of the
lemon Girl Scout cookies.
- Mm. Yeah.
I'm gonna put this in a spice grinder.
Have you used spice grinder before?
- [Ceara] I have not.
- [Rie] So you gonna just hold the pulse-
- On the top.
- And press the black button.
And now I'm going to sift.
All right.
Now, we have lemony pound cake powder.
And let's go to the next step.
We have lobsters.
- I would not think
about a lemon pound cake
and lobsters together.
- So now we are gonna cook lobster,
and lobster cooks kind of quickly.
Indicator is it turns bright red.
So it takes about four to five minutes.
You don't want to overcook it.
It's become very rubbery.
- [Producer] Let me
give you a lobster fact.
The largest lobster ever
caught weighed 44 pounds.
- Wow.
Did they eat it?
- That's scary.
- [Producer] It was three
and a half feet long.
- No. No.
- Wow!
- No.
- But I'm like, mm, that sounds delicious.
Okay, so it's bright red,
and we are gonna chuck with ice water,
so it will stop cooking.
All right, so we have an Instant Pot,
and we have some aromatic.
We have onion, celery, caramel,
and I'm going to saute.
Do you have any idea what I'm doing?
- I have a sense that we're
gonna make a lobster stock.
- Mm.
It's a good guess.
I'm gonna saute.
Have you used Instant Pot before?
- I have not.
- [Rie] It's a really great tool.
Kind of shortcut for time.
We're gonna saute until mirepoix is soft.
I think this is great.
All the vegetables are soft.
And now I'm going to use salt.
It kind of helps cooking process faster
'cause it draws moisture.
And now this is the lobster shell.
- Okay.
- We roast it in the
oven, and it's very...
It has a strong smell.
- [Ceara] Yes.
- It's like concentrated lobster.
But it's going to in a stock.
- Mm-hmm. Oh, I got it right.
(Rie laughs)
- All right, so now,
Ceara, the pound cake.
- Yes, I'm intrigued.
This feels strange.
- So the pound cake kind
of helps thicken the stock.
All of the herb stem has
very, very good flavor.
Especially it's good for making stocks.
That is the Parmesan.
Good job.
I'm gonna add water.
Bay leaf.
Bell pepper.
It looks like we're just
throwing everything in the pot
and hope for the best, but trust me,
this is gonna be very tasty.
We are going to pressure-cook
this about 45 minutes.
All right, so we have double-0
flour and semolina flour
and dehydrated Starbucks
lemon pound cake flour.
Can you put all the flour into this bowl?
- [Ceara] Yes.
- [Rie] Nice.
- And then last but not least,
the lemon pound cake powder.
- And I have whole eggs, olive
oil, dragon fruit powder.
I chose it because your
favorite color is pink.
- Yes.
- [Rie] This makes it super pretty.
- [Ceara] Oh, that's exciting.
- ASMR.
Now, I'm going to make a well.
So I'm going to pour.
It looks like a volcano.
Can you put egg yolk? Nice.
- [Ceara] It's kind of pretty.
- And I'm going to mix, try
not to break the well yet.
And slowly incorporate flour.
Oops.
Things you don't want to happen.
Thank you.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Rie] Do you wanna try?
- Okay, so just like...
- Yeah. Can you guess what
we are making right now?
- Pasta?
- Yes.
Have you made pasta from scratch?
- No.
- [Rie] It's labor intensive,
but it is fun to make.
- [Ceara] Yes.
- [Rie] Do you wanna try?
That's great.
- Wait.
Does the dragon fruit powder in the pasta
change the way it tastes?
- It doesn't.
We only use a little bit,
like not too much amount,
and the dragon fruit powder is very mild.
I think we are almost there.
All right. So we have to rest the dough.
When we work with dough, it
becomes very, very tough,
so we have to relax the gluten.
And then we have more things to do.
- Okay.
(Rie laughs)
- So I have ricotta,
Parmesan cheese, lemon zest,
and our old friend.
So I'm gonna put everything
in a food processor.
Parmesan cheese, lemon
zest, salt, and icing.
I'm gonna blend.
I'm going to put everything in the bowl.
Do you cook a lot at home?
- Sometimes. I probably
bake more than I cook.
- What is your favorite thing to bake?
- The craziest cake I ever made
'cause I was in an edible
cookie dough phase.
A chocolate cake, a layer
of edible cookie dough,
and then a layer of chocolate cake,
and then a layer of edible cookie dough,
chocolate frosting, and
then cookie crumbs, and...
It was a lot.
- Okay.
- It was a lot.
- So we have ricotta
cheese mix right here.
Can you add the olives?
- [Ceara] Yes.
- [Rie] Nice.
We didn't put it in food processor,
because sometimes, fresh
olives get bruised in-
- Oh, interesting.
There's a pasta piece.
- Yes.
- There's a lobster piece.
- Mm-hmm.
- There's a stock piece.
And now there's a ricotta piece.
You've lost me.
(Rie laughs)
- Looks good.
This is only the beginning.
- Okay.
So this is the pasta dough we rested,
and I'm going to cut in a quarter.
Very nice.
We are going to start with number one.
I'm going to go up until seven.
So can you start catching my dough?
I want to make it perfect rectangle,
so I'm going to fold it,
and I'm going to put it here.
The last one, we are at number seven.
- Super thin, but delicate.
- Mm-hmm.
We did it!
- That's beautiful.
- Yeah. I love the color.
- It's gonna look so good.
- All right, so this is
the pasta we rolled out.
We're gonna cut out in a cookie cutter.
- [Ceara] All my strength into it.
- [Rie] Mm-hmm. Perfect!
- There we go.
- Yeah.
Yay.
This is the last one.
- Oh my gosh.
Oh no!
- That didn't happen.
- Nobody see it.
- Ooh. Wait a second.
- That was very satisfying.
Let's get fancy!
- [Ceara] Fancy time!
(upbeat music)
- All right, so we have
filling, and I'm gonna pipe.
I don't want to overfill.
So maybe this much.
When you are piping,
don't squeeze from here.
- Mm-hmm.
- Squeeze from top.
This is just a support.
- [Ceara] Okay. And squeeze from the top.
- Mm-hmm. And you kinda
wanna do it straight.
- [Ceara] Yep.
- [Rie] Good, good.
We are going to close.
- Okay.
- We are going to use water.
So just wet around the edge,
and then you are going to push and hold.
Just close.
- [Ceara] So I paint the
edges and then I push-
- Push the-
- In the middle.
- [Ceara] The middle.
Like make the corners touch?
- Mm-hmm. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cute.
- Yeah.
I think that I thought the lobster
was gonna be in the ravioli.
My mind is still thinking.
- And let's cook them off.
But actually, I don't know the
name of this pasta because-
- It's a special shape.
- Do you wanna guess?
- I know it's gonna sound Italian.
- [Producer] This is "Make It Fancy."
We couldn't just do tortellini,
but the fancy version.
- Uh-huh.
- [Producer] And this
is actually cappelletti.
- It did sound Italian, though.
- Yeah.
Oh, you said your grandma is
looking forward to watch you.
- Yes.
- On YouTube, right?
- Yes. Yes.
- You wanna say hi to your grandma?
- Hi, grandmom.
- Shout out.
We cook all the...
- Cappelletti?
- Cappelletti.
When you are cooking at home,
if you have to cook the pasta ahead,
you can drizzle some olive oil,
so it doesn't stick together.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
- It's very convenient.
- Mm-hmm. Tasty hack.
We still have lobster to cook,
so can you add olive oil?
Just like a swirl.
Can you add shallot?
So we're gonna saute shallots first.
- [Ceara] Okay.
- 'Cause garlic tend to brown too quickly.
I like cooking with shallots
because shallots are fancy.
I think it's less sharp than onion.
All right. So it's nice and soft.
Can you add garlic and
saute until fragrant
and it starts smelling really nice?
- Yes.
- Now, you wanna add lobster stock.
This is the stock we cooked
in a pressure cooker,
and we strained it.
And we are going to bring it to a boil.
- What did the Parmesan
cheese and the stock do?
- Cheese rind.
It usually gets thrown
away, but it gives umami.
It gives nice, savory,
deep flavor to the stock.
- Okay. Learned something new today.
- Yeah, good question.
So it looks good.
And I'm going to strain.
I just want to have a
essence of all the flavor.
This is strained back into the pot,
and we are gonna put cream and lemon zest.
Just kind of give a nice sharpness.
- Gotta reinforce the lemon pound cake.
- Yeah, exactly.
And Parmesan cheese.
Then I'm gonna put butter.
Once the butter is melted and
the sauce is nice and creamy,
we are going to put the lobster.
Lobster is already cooked,
so we are just kind of warming up.
It's like very elegant.
- It really is. It's fancy.
- It's fancy.
- We reduced sauce a little bit,
so it's very nice and thick,
and we are gonna start plating.
Lemon zest, pea shoot,
and now I'm gonna shave truffle.
Do you wanna add edible flower?
And we are done.
- Done!
(upbeat music)
Starbucks lemon loaf
cappelletti with lobster.
Super fancy.
- It looks fancy.
And I think it's really unexpected.
- Yes, that's what I wanted to hear.
We gotta do a taste test.
We usually have a guest
to taste our creation.
Since you helped me today,
is there anybody you wanna surprise?
- I would love to
surprise my cousin Shelly.
- Okay. Shelly!
All right.
- Hi.
- Funny seeing you here.
- Do you wanna open the cover?
- Yes, I do. All right.
- Ta da!
- Oh my goodness, that looks so good.
- So we made a Starbucks
lemon loaf cappelletti
with lobster.
- That sounds very delicious.
- Yes.
- And I'm excited to try it.
- Let's try!
- Okay.
- I'm super excited.
- [Ceara] I am, too.
- Oh, that is delicious.
- That's so good.
I like how it's really,
really lemony and bright.
- I like the plating. It's very artsy.
- Can you guess how did we incorporate?
- This is hard.
I feel like...
I'm assuming part of the
sauce, it tastes lemony.
I'm curious about what
the actual pasta shell
is made out of,
so I feel like it might be
a little bit in there, too,
especially 'cause it was like bread.
- I think you nailed it, Shelly.
- Yeah.
- Maybe I should be a cook.
I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
- Did we make Starbucks lemon loaf fancy?
- Absolutely.
With the truffle and everything,
this is one of the fancier meals I've had.
- Yes!
We did it!
We have one last thing to do.
Three, two, one.
- [All] Make it fancy!
- Woo!
(everyone cheering)
(upbeat music)